welcome to this video playing come on
Radha Montes who is that actually no
name son English symmetrical answer it's
a very fashionable align nowadays here
understandably its sides interesting for
black yeah that looks funny but it is
the way it is played 95 back now he
cannot get any go anywhere else check
and castles 25 I believe I don't know
Queen III or C 3 I really don't know
I've looked at this for blackmail
sometimes difficult to remember if you
only have looked at it for black for the
other color anyway I concluded that
black has decent play and decided to
make that part of my opening repertoire
I would love to get the bishops traded
dark squared bishop switch
not so easy of course blacks play is
based on the on the bishop pair as it is
so often queen bee three ma'am maybe
queen bee three doubling the points
there is not great from structural point
of view but it makes sure that is not
easily playing civ 5 interesting I can
play Bishop f4 that makes rupee 8 look
rather debatable so 90 to see four hours
the idea anyway so let's do it
interesting interesting 95 I had not
said not really leading anywhere look a
form okay for a five maybe group before
I it's probably a draw check I didn't
see anything better unfortunately
is it really a draw how came in it is a
drawn but I'm just thinking of ways to
there there
yeah I'm upon down and no time thats
that's the worst part the position is
not really that big a deal let me think
about it
I probably didn't play it particularly
well but I still think it's wrong
especially after we can actually play
King a full-time morning that's rather
stupid that was that it's one of those
totally unnecessary losses this end game
is just a complete draw from the get-go
and I failed yeah it is unfortunately
very easy to win ah rubbish nah come on
white resins and I mean okay that that I
never never ever ever ever can do with
ready yeah i got into fairly passive
position down it's still it still should
be a draw but he can torture me already
which shouldn't really happen because um
in this in this position here if anybody
is better it's white it can never be
black so this means that maybe this
night if this rook a for business wasn't
a particularly great idea oh I can go
bishops his own and be better okay
yeah I was basically seeing the clock
and thought okay that's check let's do
this trade down to a draw yeah this was
an unnecessary move the my main issue
was I didn't really see how quick visual
a 63 is coming i mean i can just do this
and now look a one that is much stronger
much much stronger here it's a it's
pretty much a draw immediately yeah okay
that's it that's that that's what i need
to do and not really do anything else
that's just completely completely okay
and equal yeah and the end game then
that was mean still feel that shouldn't
be a draw but i didn't defend well
really i was just shuffling around with
no idea each one is it at some time I
cannot blame it on the time I have to do
this to get porn straight it let's say
this this and maybe look over here to e5
or something mastered and studies draw I
come on it's the wrong okay so i had to
play this Bishop c7 over here to avoid
trouble okay thanks for watching